you
okay so welcome to I think this is the
eighth lecture although I'm starting to
lose count and this year's science and
cooking lecture series and we're really
honored to have with us
Martin Breslin who's the chef for
Harvard for HUDs for Harvard and we also
have Alex and Louise and we're really
honored to have them with us we've been
doing this at Harvard for many years and
we finally get to have Harvard's
chefs talk in this series and so I guess
I'd just like to start by clapping for
that and actually so what they're gonna
illustrate for us today is really one of
the most fascinating parts of cooking I
think which is the science of texture
how it is that you actually thicken
sauces and what is the science behind
that and okay so now just to introduce
the science of this I wanted to start by
showing you the lab that we're doing
actually right now now starting on
Thursday I'm in the Harvard College quad
are we doing it right now we're doing it
right now the lab that we're doing right
now in the Harvard College class that
goes along with this lecture that the
chefs are about to give us and this is a
sort of funny lab it's called macaroni
and cheese is that we have the students
and it's in the lab it's in one of the
labs over there in one of the science
labs they make macaroni and cheese and
what we ask them to do is a bit strange
which is that we asked them to make four
different varieties of macaroni and
cheese you see we asked them to make it
with all of these different things and
then we asked them to measure what we
call the viscosity which is the
scientific term that basically goes with
thickeners which is sort of when you say
a sauce is thickening then what the
scientists would say is well it's more
viscous and we asked them to measure the
viscosity and in order to demonstrate
that this viscosity this is actually
sort of how thick it feels in your mouth
but it also has culinary significance in
different ways and the method that we
use for them to measure the viscosity is
well I was going to call it brilliant
but that's probably overstating it is
this is what we do is we tell them to
take a cup full of macaroni and then to
pour the sauce on top of it and to
basically measure how quickly the sauce
covers the macaroni which is of course
measuring how quickly
how easily it flows now in this room in
past years when we've discussed
viscosity
we've even brought with us scientific
pieces of equipment that are very fancy
that are going to the name of rheometer
x' that basically measure the viscous
properties of liquids and they're very
oh so Tareq and there are things that
like pia and i and dave like but that
most people don't like and it's really
less relevant this is really the key
experiment actually this picture was
taken from last year's harvardx class if
you took the harvardx class you also got
to do this lab and here are some
pictures from the harvardx class but
what I want to do at the moment is to
ask the question which I think will
underlie this entire lecture which is
why is it that some of these sauces
spread so much more easily than others
that is what is it about the way that
their make made that makes them
something viscous and others not and if
you want to think about the least
viscous thing that I can imagine it's
basically water so water is the least
viscous thing and you can imagine if you
took water and you poured it down this
column of macaroni what would happen it
would just go right to the bottom right
it would go very quickly and go right to
the bottom and this whole art of
thickening sauces that we're about to
see is really about making that not
happen and is somehow making it fall
slowly so what is going on ok so what is
viscosity so I already said this that's
the thickness of the liquid or liquids
resistance to flow sort of on the other
side of the scale for viscous water as
them is the has the lowest viscosity
honey of course has a very high
viscosity it basically Falls very slowly
but even another cooking material that
out that also has a high viscosity which
you may not think of this way is dough
because after all if you take a ball of
dough and you put it on the on the table
and we waited until the end of the
lecture it would have spread out and
flattened even more slowly than honey
would and so what is going on so what is
the molecular origin of this so these
two pictures actually we we got from
Nathan Myhrvold who has put together
some of the videos for the Harvard X
version of the class who had what I
think is a brilliant analogy of what's
going on and I'm going to tell it you
and when you watch these guys if you
want a scientific analogy in the back of
your head I recommend this one so what
Nathan said is imagine that you're
you're going to the subway right and
you're going and you know you and
imagine you go during a time you know on
the weekend and there aren't many people
there and you go from the you know the
place where you give your ticket to the
train and you just walk very quickly and
there's no problem we all could walk
very quickly there's no problem to get
to the Train so that's not viscous
because we move very quickly so on the
other hand imagine a situation which is
like this where the subway car is full
of people right there are lots of people
there then it's very slow you could
still flow we could be moving but you
know when you're driving do any of you
have this problem you're driving down
the road and the idiot in front of you
isn't going fast enough maybe it's just
me I'm the one behind you that's honking
you know and you're always like well why
is this like don't they know how to
drive I may not have made just me who
does this and in reality what's
happening is is that the poor person has
this set of people in front of them and
they're they're blocking it and that's
viscosity so what are some of the
messages and when these guys are making
sauces that are thick what they're doing
is they're adding stuff to impede mouton
movement they're making it the packing
fraction big that's what we're going to
say you're just putting stuff in there
to make it so that it doesn't move ok so
then of course you know and also from
this example you also know I don't know
if you've ever experienced that
certainly you've experienced that while
driving is if you pack enough people in
the roadway you stop has anyone noticed
that ok so does anybody know so ok
here's a question for you this is gonna
sound like a crazy question and we
didn't bring them does anybody have some
M&Ms no M&Ms so no I mean I'm so suppose
you took a jar of M&Ms right you just
shook it the M&M stopped they're not
flowing does anyone to know what
fraction of the jar is filled with M&Ms
this actually is it good for the kids in
the audience if they're any kids you or
even the grown-ups if you want to help
your child win and mmm candy counting
contest this is the number you need to
know I mean the question is what
fraction of the jar is filled with M&Ms
does anybody know is it 50% you know
there's air in the dryer if you notice
this so it turns out there's a magic
number it's about 65% that's that's the
fraction so basically if you ever get
the volume fraction of the stuff up to
65% it stops if you get it if it's like
30% it doesn't matter it'll flow easily
you might as well not put anything in
so there's this magic range at about
50-60 percent and that's where you want
to get to in these guys and all of these
sauces they're gonna make what you're
gonna see is what they're doing is
they're getting the fraction up to
around that range so this is a movie of
molecules flowing over each other so see
they don't run into each other so the
viscosity is actually there's no problem
here
but on the other hand if you do with the
sort of simplest kind of a sauce that
you can imagine is a starch thickened
sauce and if you and will see it starts
to thicken sauce now if you put starch
I'm granules into a liquid you can put
them so there's this weird thing that
happens you can put them at a pretty low
concentration a little volume fraction
is what we will say because sort of
there's a lot of free space here for
these things to move if you imagine
these as people in the subway car
they're not running into each other but
then the point is when you heat it they
swell and not only do they swell they
exclude excrete stuff they swell and
they excrete stuff and then what happens
is they end up like this
and if you imagine that this is people
in the subway car then you see now it
doesn't move so easily and that's
basically what it means this is the crux
of what it means to think in a sauce and
I have a little movie of this courtesy
of Harvard X you see the day so
basically and they also can stick to
each other not do they grow they stick
to each other and now if they stick to
each other they even become bigger
people so if you imagine the analogy in
the subway car imagine that there are
groups of people that decide to join
hands and pummel through right that's
then you're gonna get mad if you're the
poor person walking he's only making it
harder to get through and that's exactly
what happens when you make sauces as
we're seeing and so this brings up which
is the equation of this week now what
are you supposed to do for the equation
of the week
so anyway but this is the equation and
it's a very simple equation and this
captures the whole idea of thickening
sauces which is it's the volume fraction
for some reason we call it fee Greek
letters just to make it sound
complicated but it's just the number of
particles times the volume of each
particle divided by the total volume and
basically the game is when that number
gets to be a 50 60 percent your good
your thickened your sauce okay so now I
have one more thing to say I do have one
more thing to say sorry but I think this
is important for what you're gonna do
and I just want to so you know when you
add flour has anyone ever thickened
gravy
I mean how much flour do you add a lot a
little a little because it swells right
that's why you don't have to add very
much because it swells so has anyone
ever thickened um you know sort of made
something more viscous by adding like a
like an anthem gum or some modernist
thickener do you know how much you need
teeny teeny teeny do you know how much
of the jello box is gelatin yeah it's
very very that most of that jello box
you know what the main ingredient is in
the jello box sugar it's sugar it's not
Stella so so this is amazing actually
cuz if you think of this in terms of
volume fraction this is totally weird
because you add this little bit of this
stuff into this big amount of liquid and
it comes out and like if we go back to
the subway cars how does it work so the
answer is that that what happens is that
that these special molecules are
polymers and the weight and there's not
very much polymer but the polymer
basically forms a path and space which
creates a lot of volume and so it
actually takes up a lot of volume even
though it's just a little polymer in the
same way that the starch granule it
expands and it takes that much more
volume that it had originally the
polymer sort of sweeps it out and takes
up that's much volume and that's why
modern has thickeners are able to work
and make thick milkshake feeling things
with a little bit of additive okay so
with that I guess I would like to
introduce Martin and Alex and Louise who
will tell us how this is really done
thank you Michael
chef Luis decosta he's in charge of our
commissary where all the soup and sauces
are produced so viscosity is very
important when we're producing large
quantities of soups and sauces and chef
Alex takes care of Mather house students
so we you know work for the for Harvard
and primarily support the undergraduate
program so a history of thickening of
thickeners right when you it was very
interesting I was looking at this from a
food historical perspective so the word
sauce is a French word and it means to
make our food appetizing sounds good so
go back 2,000 years ago and the first
real recorded recipes were from the
Roman Empire and and it was s piscis if
I'm pronouncing that correctly said and
recipes for its particular flavor some
sauce is noted that no one at the table
will know what they are eating the
sauces were usually thickened with wheat
flour or crumbled pastry honey was often
added and the reason was the Romans
often use sauces to conceal doubtful
freshness so in truth that really the
French were right it does make the food
taste better can make really bad food
taste better so we've got to ask herself
so that's actually Pompeii and they're
the ovens in Pompeii and it's pretty
cool because if you've ever been there
they're all communal kitchens which is
pretty amazing and bakeries and very
much like a retail concept very few
people cooked at home so why do we
thicken would anyone like to give some
suggestions to why we thicken our food
huh mouthfeel so mouthfeel is the number
one reason why we thicken our food and
that's important because we you know if
you're if you're thinking it tasting a
clear broth it's going to taste you're
gonna get a very different experience if
you thicken even just thicken that broth
and do nothing else another one of
course is clean so when you're putting a
sauce on food you want it to clean
to the food you don't need to run off
the food could you imagine a steak au
poivre that wasn't thickened so cling is
very important and keeping sauces on the
plate and of course then we have
particle suspension whole salads and
prevents sticking or floating and
stabilized emulsions when you're talking
about salad dressings and so on so
they're the real main there are I'm sure
more reasons but that's the most
important reasons why we thicken our
food the thickening process dispersion
hydration and setting so when we're
adding a thickening agent we want to
make sure it's evenly distributed
throughout the liquid we could use heat
cold acid or other liquids depending on
what you're using to thicken the food so
and then hydration you want it's gonna
absorb water or another liquid and it'll
swell that's how it thickens howdy the
thickening agent will make a thick
molecular mesh that traps water and
Michael could definitely explain that
much better than I will and setting
that's the effective temperature if
you're using gelatin of course it's
going to set when you chill it now we're
going to start by showing you some
thickening agents and can work so the
first one I'm going to use is blood so
if you're familiar with coq au van
traditionally it was thickened for blood
there's a quite a few dishes in the
French culinary repertoire that were
thickened with blood and believe it not
you can buy blood so when you're adding
blood and I'll show you it'll liaison as
well you with blood you add vinegar and
we had a great discussion area about
what relief that does so you had a
little bit of vinegar to the blood and
it does stop it from coagulating just a
drop and another important feature when
you're using blood you want to temper it
so tempering it is just you don't want
to shock it going into a hot sauce I'm
just gonna take a little bit of the
sauce and temper it here I might just
add a little bit more blood why not and
many cultures today still use I mean you
might tell from my accent that I come
from across the pond and
we use blood sausage all the time for
breakfast so blood is still a part of of
dining in Ireland so what you want to do
is like you're doing a Montejo of beer I
just gently fold in the blood
so look gross
now do you notice what's happening the
colors changing right and I can see a
thickening here
a little bit more heat so I will show
you I'm just heating it a tiny bit more
you don't want it to go over 180 degrees
or you will have rambled blood so it
actually gives to this dish a very rich
complex sometimes it could be a little
metallic and you can see if you can do
you see the color and that's pretty
thick and it's very rich in Cocoa Van is
a very rich dish when you eat it it's a
nice winter dish and that is taco van
thickened with blood and we can finish
it with some parsley
now that's a beautiful look at the shine
and that sauce it's really nice so the
next thickener is was used also in
classic French cuisine and it's called a
liaison and eleazar basically two things
coming together right and we have egg
yolks and cream now egg yolks are the
same they go over 180 degrees you're
going to have scrambled and it's sauce
with a really lumpy texture okay so
you're familiar with an assault scald a
veloute
so veloute know so veloute is a velvet
sauce and it gets its name from a
liaison and a lot of restaurants that
say they serve a salute a really it's
not a veloute so but they you it's very
difficult to get that texture without
mr. crane oh yeah without using a
liaison and it can and what makes this
difficult to do when you're cooking is
that it can only be done last minute
that means when the sauce is ready to be
served
you put the liaison on and it goes out
you can't reheat it it's going to turn
into scrambled eggs and it gives a very
very unique texture
so thanks Alex
so yet again I'm gonna just temporarily
haze on a little bit with some of the
this is just chicken stock with a very
small roux
not a full rule that was chicken it so
now it should take on a velvety
appearance this is exactly what this
will do and it makes it for a very
different mouthfeel it's very rich quite
delicious too
now I can feel that sauce F is
thickening and if you can see right
we don't have scrambled eggs that's a
good thing and that is Coco van and a
veloute and I'm gonna pass you down to
Alex and Alex is going to show you two
more thickening and Alex is going to
demonstrate arrowroot and cornstarch as
a thickening agent I'm going to talk
about two more starches arrowroot and
cornstarch and I'm gonna make two simple
sauces that we all can do the first the
first our sauce I'm gonna make is a
simple sweet and sour sauce and I'm
gonna use cornstarch cornstarch is a
starch from corn and and it has a strong
flavor and leaves an Opie color it's
it's not the perfect starts to use for a
clear finishing product but for a lot of
Asian dishes the cornstarch is good for
hot cold sweet savory dishes and it's
pretty universal it the the cons to
using cornstarch is that it doesn't
recover from being frozen and the flavor
if you use too much the flavor is strong
but the positive side of cornstarch is
gluten free and you know with all the
allergens going on in the world today
this is a good alternative so simple we
add all the ingredients a cup of soy
three tablespoons of sugar
a cup of rice wine vinegar and about a
half a cup of ketchup so to use corn
starch as a thickener you have to make
what's called a slurry and a slurry is
basically equal parts flour and water to
a thick liquefied paste and the reason
why you make a slurry is that if you add
the cornstarch straight to the sauce
you would have clumps and lumps of
little little pillows of our corn starch
that won't blend properly with make sure
everything is incorporated and I'll
start the slurry
all right okay so you mix the water and
the cornstarch together you have your
slurry and when the sauce is up to a
boil it's the is the perfect time to add
the slurry in the sauce definitely needs
to be boiling it needs to be above 180
degrees and the slurry needs to start
with cold water you can't start with hot
water because they will definitely do
something different to the thickening
where it will premature thicken the
slurry but not thicken the sauce and
you'll have a broken broken sauce
it's most good from here that in just a
little pineapple juice oh that was
pineapple juice see I'm counting volume
fraction no you guys are watching him
cook and I'm counting volume fraction so
he put how much water did you put it in
in this word it was about a half a cup a
half a cup of water and there's much
more than a cup of the sauce and this is
a couple cups of sauce isn't it it is a
couple of cups of some actually
naturality I'm probably not gonna need
all of the slurry so attendees your
hands you I mean you want to add slowly
stir and as you can see the color has
changed
that's pretty thick that's thick
did you see that I mean I know you've
thicken sauces before but it's amazing
like you just put it a little of that
stuff and I've got that much thicker so
here I'm gonna make a blueberry compote
which would basically be like a dessert
sauce or could be could be used as a pie
filling and I'm gonna thicken this sauce
with arrowroot and the reason why I am
using our Roux because our roux has one
a neutral flavor when using our fruit
it's it's best to have a neutral flavor
something not it's gonna overpower the
fruit so I have some frozen blueberries
some orange juice
and just like the cornstarch I'm gonna
make a slurry with the error let's go
so our road is a is a plant from the
Caribbean and it has a very strong
holding power four times as much as
flour and it is it's a very very good
good choice like I said for a fruit dish
and it's also gluten free but here it is
again the slurry but the same
consistency the blueberries are coming
to a boil and I'm going to slowly add
the reason why I slowly add is because
as as the sauce thickens
sometimes the stages take longer or
shorter and I just don't want to go over
go-go less so I'm just gonna add slow
and as you can see it's really
thickening up depending on what you're
gonna use it for right now if I was
going to now pay this sauce over a
pastry or a cake I would stop here if I
was gonna use this as a pie filling I
would go a little bit more and then I'll
go one more as if we're gonna fill this
Thanks that concludes the the cornstarch
and our gonna pass it to Louise Louise
is going to demonstrate thanks Alex
Louise is going to demonstrate roux as a
thickening agent and while he's doing
that you're gonna taste what he's making
and that's New England clam chowder
that's served here for the undergraduate
students every Friday so we have a
sampling coming up and Louise added
butter right I toss the vegetables add
in salary and then I'm gonna head on
ease to it let it cook a little bit
Louise so many gallons of chowder do you
make every Thursday for Friday
Everage are on the ball 200 gallons to
100 gallons a chatter that's a lot of
chatter it's a quite a lot of solids
yells think you need a bigger pot some
basically most flat into vegetables now
I'm gonna add two bottom
bacon Luis yeah and I'm adding the bacon
just added flour so he what Louise is
doing he's making a white roux
and it's that's even amount of flour and
butter so there's a white roux a blond
roux and then there's a dark roux and
the dark roux is used if you're making
in a to say and in Louisiana nice dark
I'll be heading to crime it's more
cheddar Krista has it right here
a lot of bay leaves yep time he's doing
these things are getting ticket
beautiful nice call gonna add the
potatoes
and Italy's loss is the clams
salt and pepper flavor the other climb
shot is done actually
okay so the next one we're going to show
you is xantham gum and xanthan gum is in
a lot of foods that you eat because it
is a stabilizer and and a thickener
so you ever make tuna salad and you you
go to the tuna salad
you know maybe two hours later and it's
kind of milk coming off the tuna salad
right the mayonnaise has turned to milky
so we've got some white tuna meat some
blanched celery oops some mayonnaise
Simba lemon juice
look the salt and pepper and that's tuna
salad right but that tuna salads not
going to stay like that if you were
making that for tomorrow you're gonna
have it'll break down a bit the
mayonnaise will break down the water
from the tuna will start coming out it's
in cans full of water or pouches and
xantham gum doesn't take a lot a little
bit of Santa gum will keep that doesn't
taste doesn't interfere with the taste
of the product but this will still look
like this tomorrow so that's it that's
all it takes that's all it takes and
xanthan gum is used in a cold
application xanthan gum can be used to
thicken dressings oils so you've gotta
think of cold for xanthan gum so does
anybody know what it's doing I mean
there wasn't very much xantham gum it
doesn't need much yeah so I mean
presumably the xanthan gum is a polymer
and presumably as such it's making a gel
in the water and that's trapping the
water and not letting it out and I mean
what's amazing is that such a small
amount I mean I barely put any in just a
little spring a little pinch does
anybody know where xanthan gum comes
from this is like the quiz night
bacteria yep so one more and I'm going
to show you an emulsion so and I'm going
to just do this so you can actually see
what that's just some shallots right
some Dijon mustard should be over here
right
and vinegar you know we would know me do
like 3 2 1
something like that now you can see that
this is separated it's really not doing
a whole lot but just by putting an
immersion blender
and a little bit of salt and pepper and
you've got a nice dressing and it's rice
wine vinegar Dijon and olive oil but
that could be any vinegar you like and
you could go to a milder oil like a
canola
but that has the consistency of a thick
sauce it does tend to when you make it
you do need to it won't fully separate
like an Italian dressing but just before
you use it you can just blend it or
whisk it does anybody know why before I
put it under the microscope
does anybody know okay boy the mustard
is important for this yeah okay wait
you're getting ahead of us but do you
disable do you know what we're gonna see
let's see if this works
I shouldn't isn't that amazing
they're droplets so what Martin has done
and I mean I think this is really
amazing so sorry I I mean you've seen
this before probably you've done this
yourself but you saw what he did he pour
it in some oil
he poured in some vinegar he put in a
little bit of mustard there was the oil
separated from the vinegar and then he
just blended it and look at all the
little droplets that he made